[Music]
[Applause]
you graduates are coming of age in an
amazing time
as americans we enjoy more freedoms and
opportunities
than citizens in any other nation on
earth
so my american dream is pretty simple my
american dream is just not living
paycheck to paycheck
we have the chance to get an education
and work hard and give our children a
better life you don't go to college you
you don't get a job like that's the only
way you can make a living for yourself
the challenge for our generation is to
create a world where everyone has a
sense of purpose
from a pretty early age i knew i wanted
to be an orthodontist
what has always been certain
is the ability to shape that destiny
my mom was a teacher i just ended up
falling in love with history and went
down that track
you will be happy
you will be successful
and you will make a difference in the
world
congratulations on your graduation
a college degree is a signal
attend the best possible university you
can get into you'd be wrong to forego a
college education the return on a
college education has never been greater
what it is a signal of is i am able to
speak a certain way and understand a
certain set of cultural tropes
and this group of people maybe not so
much financing college is very tough for
millions of americans tuition has gone
through the roof post-secondary
education is now the largest source of
consumer borrowing behind mortgage loans
so many families are borrowing to the
teeth
and the thing that we say to these kids
is do this shtick in high school and it
will get you into college and then we
say now do it again
and it will get you a job they fell into
a trap our society is created for them
student loan debt has been steadily
increasing affecting approximately 44
million americans
the cost of getting a college education
is having a lasting effect on graduates
it's just so natural like everyone does
it this is good debt thirteen thousand
dollars can turn into 25 000 easily
there's a good return on investment i'm
paying all these bills and i have
nothing you did this to chase the
american dream that we all cherish
people are alive but not living this is
not the way the american dream was set
up you know here i am 36 i have a
million dollars in student loans
every piece in the system did what it
was supposed to do
and the victims are 17 years old
the stories all come down to one theme
how has this happened to me when i did
everything right
i remember mad when i was
you know 17
a guy walked in from a local college
there in the city of fayetteville and
said hey if you haven't started thinking
about college education you are you are
late
and if you really want to be successful
you have to go to college because if you
do not go to college you will not be
successful
i didn't know how to process it
my entire young life i was never taught
the proper education of what i needed to
be successful i was just told go to
college you will be successful
and if you have to take out student
loans that's okay everyone is doing it
and i became like everyone
the culture in the last three to four
decades has dramatically
shifted
it used to be
that we said education is important
study something so that you can further
your career
it moved from that to where education
was permission to play you weren't going
to be valid in the economy unless you
had a four-year or more degree
not only is it necessary but it's like a
guarantee
that you're guaranteed to be more
successful and so you have to have this
because a degree is the answer
society has rules and the first rule is
you go to college
you want to have a happy and successful
life you go to college if you want to be
somebody you go to college if you want
to fit in you go to college
is a four-year college degree still a
good investment i mean not surprisingly
the principal you think is a good a good
investment for a couple of reasons one a
student is going to earn a million
dollars more over their lifetime career
if opposed if they didn't have a college
degree they'll be more nimble they have
lower rates of unemployment even robert
johnson said they're going to live
longer because they're likely to have
better insurance
okay
we set the table in such a way
that we doomed
millions of parents and kids to take the
bait
when we elevated the pursuit of a
four-year degree to here
we
inversely
relegated
a two-year degree or a community college
or an apprenticeship program or all
those other things
down here
higher education became a thing
everything else became
an alternative
there was some studies that came out and
said if you have a college degree you
will make this much more in your
lifetime that became the marketing
slogan for higher ed which is if you
come do this
you make more money the shift of a
public good turned into a private good
i'm getting my degree so i can make more
money for me
then the markets got involved and this
thing was not something we all invested
in like roads or police or fire
departments it became a way for me to
get rich
the cost of college
has grown faster
than the cost of energy
and the cost of real estate
the cost of health care
all of it
somehow we got it into our heads that
it's priceless
and we've told an entire generation of
kids if they don't borrow whatever it
takes
then they're going to enter into this
crazy rat race hopelessly disadvantaged
so you had a 17 18 year old kid
being told
to sign on the dotted line or else
his parents aren't cautioning him not to
do that guidance counselors aren't
saying hey take a breath be careful
nobody is
i think where this really becomes a
crisis is millions of people who
faithfully pay their student loan bill
every month where that debt is having an
enormous implication on their lives and
their communities things like the
ability to buy a house save for
retirement what career you choose even
if you're gonna start a family
it's this unintentional consequence of
just living in society and being
surrounded by
everything that says spend and have a
certain lifestyle and it's okay to
borrow and to go into debt and just make
sure you can afford the payments
they're just following the normal path
normal ended me in the back of my car
because i didn't have nowhere to sleep
normal ended me in the ymca washing
myself because i didn't have a home to
go to and take a shower
before i even turn 19 i'm 35 000 in debt
i was that young kid thinking about
committing suicide
i was that young kid wondering how am i
going to eat
it was during that season in my life
that i decided that i'm i'm sick and
tired of being sick and tired
i'm tired of not being able to have the
options what can i eat what can i do
where can i go
and so i got myself out of debt
[Music]
learned a lot about money learned a lot
about life
all right anthony
had to lose some friends had to better
myself
and i said
when i get out of this
i want to be in front of young people
and help them go after their dreams but
make sure that their dreams do not
become nightmares
and when i look at this table i see
dreams but if it's going down the wrong
path i also do see future nightmares
and so i'm excited to be here with you
all tonight is to have a conversation
about your life
and what you are experiencing
you all are about to step into
the real world
what is one thing that
you're feeling about graduation
so once i get out of high school i gotta
make sure i get the right steps to make
sure that whatever i do going forward
can put my kids in a better situation
than i am does that make you fearful
though are you nervous about that yeah
god
i'm a teenager you know i make bone-head
decisions
so like my small decision can play a big
role in my future
hey but you know what at least you admit
that right unless i'm a teenager i'm
gonna make some dumb decisions
what is one decision you're scared of
making
i want to enjoy my life to the fullest
cause i live for now and then i also got
to live for the future so you don't know
which one you want to choose my mom
tells me all the time to do what makes
me happy you support me 100
um but then i also have my dad um he
tells me look you have to pick something
it has to be something that's high
paying because you have to feed yourself
you know and we're in a society today
where you can't just not go to college
or like well you can but it can be a
little rough
of course growing up your parents always
tell you you can do anything you want to
do you can do anything you put your mind
dude
if you work hard in high school and you
keep these good grades and take these
classes you can go anywhere you want to
go well they don't tell you that there's
a
180 000 price tag attached to it so do
you think college is the only way you
can be successful in life yes
always
going to college is like a safety net no
matter what you do in life no matter
what dreams you chase if you have a
degree to fall back on you're always
safe
so
my game plan was the game plan that
everyone else had
i'm gonna apply to get student loans
i always thought everything's just gonna
be fine everything will sort itself out
college was always in the picture
older brother went to college older
sister went to college so me being the
youngest
also go to college and
get the best i can for myself
for that first year it was 24 000
i didn't work i played three sports
so to me it was really easy just say
this money will just take care of itself
i'll make enough money
went off to school and
didn't really worry about it for a year
until we had to do it all over again
free money free money
[Music]
get out the notes that we started on
before
we're gonna keep going over
values and beliefs and things that we
have in our society that tell us what we
can and cannot do
and so on from there i met josiah
through mutual friends
we were only dating for a couple months
and he just brought it up and i didn't
even think twice about it like everyone
had it like that's fine whatever and i
don't think it really hit me until
like the week after we got married
we
got a decent amount of money from our
wedding and that instantly like went
straight to like all of our bills and
then like
it was gone
everyone in the pictures
and they're so happy holding their
diploma walking across the stage
by the time the graduation ceremony was
i had realized it's not this happy go
lucky time
i had taken out about a hundred and ten
thousand dollars in student loans
interest had been gathering the entire
time
that had ballooned to
125 000
after four and a half years of college
it was something that i was not prepared
for
it was an avalanche coming down on me
i had a total of 11 separate bills
coming in the mail
for 870 some dollars
that i was going to pay per month
student loans on the table for you yes
man you jump straightly yes bro
i mean i'm not the first i'm not gonna
be the last like
because that's the only option
i mean
[Music]
technically no
my thing is whenever you wanna do
something you gotta take the good and
the bad with it yeah so like my thing is
if you want to be real successful you
might have to take on the dick
but it's you going to work hard to get
out of that ditch but how much that is
too much what are you really yeah like
that's the whole thing when it comes to
the student loans so like what what does
you feel like it's an enough risk for
you yeah and in life like everything
sucks everything has like a backdrop
everything has a trade-off you're never
gonna get the good only you're just
choosing what sucks less
yeah that's true
i know people that are planning to die
with that debt like they're only paying
interest i'll take the bloke like give
it to me you know so you would hold that
burden for the rest of your life yeah
paying off student loans hundreds and
hundreds yeah like when you won
something really bad you got to take all
of it
this is probably one of if not the most
important financial decisions in your
life and i think a lot of this stems
from this unfortunate
thought that we don't need to worry
about student debt because it's quote
good debt there's something about like
the word student being before the word
loan that just makes us think about this
differently
and like differently in a very bad way
[Music]
the student loan problem has reached
epidemic proportions the curve on the
growth of credit card debt even though
it's been ridiculous has been much more
gentle than the curve on student loan
debt it's gone to a mushroom cloud in
terms of the mathematics on it
the problem is is that you don't
register emotionally that it's money
i mean when you borrow money to buy a 20
000 car you have a completely different
emotional experience than if you write a
check or put down twenty thousand
dollars worth of benjamins right there
you having them you have an emotional
experience that you do not have when you
just sign and go i think i can make
those payments it's the same thing
happens with student loans there's a
whole lot of people
who have a big target on your back who
view you and your ability to take on a
ton
of debt as their chance to get rich
college tuition has risen enormously
over the past five decades why would
someone pay for this
well everyone seems to agree that
graduating from college is a guarantee
to a better life
so it's no surprise that the student
debt level has risen exponentially as
people pursue their shot at the american
dream
but is the payoff
really there
well when the student loan program was
first started by the government it had
really good intentions students could
only borrow up to a thousand dollars a
year for school
the expectation was as students
completed their higher education they
would in turn contribute their knowledge
and skills back into society
and the money for all of this came
directly from the us treasury
but as the demand for higher education
grew so did tuition now the government
had to open up the student loan program
even more so
they brought in the banks that meant the
government didn't have to foot the
initial bill anymore but they still
guaranteed the loans if the borrower
couldn't pay it back so the banks they
were getting paid one way or the other
and on top of that they got to collect
any and all interest from the loans
in business this is called making a
profit
so fast forward tuition is still rising
because the demand for college wasn't
slowing down and the banks they couldn't
keep up
this is where the government stepped in
and created the student loan marketing
association
more conveniently known as sally may
as a government sponsored enterprise
they were designed to funnel money into
the student loan program
they would buy the loans from the banks
which allowed the banks the cash flow to
issue more loans and over the next two
decades sally may became a major player
in the student loan market but in 2004
sallie mae cut their strings from the
government and became a fully
private company and this meant they were
a real business
a business that exists for one thing to
make
a profit
this is where the student loan program
went from being a public good
to big money
actually this isn't even a program
anymore
it's an industry
the real mail in the coffin though came
a year later when sally may convince
congress to make private student loans
nearly impossible to discharge through
bankruptcy this has resulted in growing
default rates record amounts of interest
accumulated and dragged out repayment
plans that never go away
now we're left with entire generations
of people trapped in student loan debt
who took it on in hopes of making a
better life for themselves because that
was the original goal of all this
but it's companies like sally may
naviance great lakes thea osla nelnet
and countless others whose pockets are
overflowing with the money
your future was supposed to be built on
so
with over 45 million americans sharing
this 1.6 trillion dollars of student
loan debt
the question
still remains
hey guys it's lacey
and i am broke as [ __ ] 200 000
172 000
in debt i went to a regular ass day
school i have only paid off seven
thousand two hundred thirty one dollars
and eleven cents how much interest have
i paid in thirteen years nineteen
thousand thirty dollars and twenty seven
cents
holy
sh
i got in there one day and it said your
loads will be forgiven if you die
well that's that's nice
so i feel like my time in college wasn't
really
the ideal picture that i had at college
i feel like college is supposed to be
fun and
the time that you're away from parents
and rules and can make your own
decisions
but
my college was pretty much filled with
how am i gonna
make sure i'm stable
my view is like it's not the end of the
world it's normal it's life to have dead
everyone has debt
everyone has it so it's fine brush it
off don't worry about it
when i got my final financial aid report
and i seen how much more
money i needed you can't start class if
you don't have a zero balance
i had to do something
i couldn't get that amount of money from
home
i talked to the financial aid advisors
that we have at our school
and they introduced me to loans
i did look at it as it was investing in
myself like it's okay
but then once i realized i had to
continue
to
take things out it was like okay wow
this is like adding up
very quickly
[Music]
it became a thing of like
dreading the fact that
i'm gonna owe so much money
when i get out of school
[Music]
that is when it like hit me the hardest
it's like you don't want to have to
being dead and so you try to comfort
yourself with the notion that it's
normal
but you don't want it so it's like a
constant like
dissonance and conflict going on through
your whole collegiate career because
you're like yeah i'm excelling
as far as i'm getting a higher education
but at the same time i'm going to be
just like everyone else
working
to pay off debt
the weight that people feel from this
decision they haven't even made their
first rent payment on an apartment they
haven't had to have their own bank
account for a lot of students like their
prefrontal cortex isn't even fully
developed yet and yet we're saying do
you want 50 000 in student loans that's
a lot to put on an 18 year old
especially when you have well-respected
adults working at banks or admissions
offices saying you know hey this is a
great thing just take out this loan it's
no big deal
people shouldn't leave college in chains
from the decision to get an education
that helps them
contribute to society that is a good
thing it's really sad to see people
struggle
as a result of this great decision to
get an education
and add another one to add another one
to the list
yeah they said some of these other bills
were going to be a little bit lower but
you never know so we might even have
additional stuff too so
come back on groceries
yeah so if we can change like what do we
need we need about 60 bucks 80 bucks
so if we can choose you think oh i have
a house we have a car we have jobs like
we're fine we're the average american
but we weren't making ends meet we were
living paycheck to paycheck and i
thought i made a decent salary
we get the taxes this month
it puts us at
about 20
short
so if i go donate plasma like another
time that's another 20 bucks or so yeah
depending on which one it is
we are on our way to
lima
to donate plasma
uh it's something that i do
usually every tuesday and thursday after
football practice
split outside linebacker's wide out
widen out have to stay in still
quarterback is still your guy because if
they do a crossbow i'll be home till
about eight or so but
gotta make this a little bit extra money
somehow
that money i make during the month
or donating is a big difference in my
life
people say like i go through a crazy
schedule but you know
i've left courtney at home for the last
12 plus hours
i worked in works and works and i worked
at a job i didn't like but i had no
choice like i have student loan payments
to make
i didn't make enough money to pay it off
in 15 years like the plan they wanted me
to
they're gonna take me 30 years to pay
off
i took up credit cards when i was on
college because that's what you do
i still had a car payment at that time
too
i was broken
i'm paying all these bills and i have
nothing
i want you to be successful i want each
and every one of you all to go after the
american drink but i got to ask you this
question
what is one thing that can stop your
dreams
dude
say it again did say that one more time
did my man
you gotta take debt off of the table
i'd rather take six years to graduate
debt freed and freedom graduating four
and i spend the next 30 years paying
back my sick lunch
let's be real
if all of you all went to college didn't
listen to my advice today
two of you all will graduate from this
table with a hundred thousand dollars or
more in debt
studies are showing that the average
person takes them 20 years
to pay back their student loan debt let
me go deeper
studies are showing that y'all right
here young people when you graduate
college
the number one goal in life is not to
get your dream job
number one goal in life is when you
graduate college it's not to go out
there and buy you a nice car and
it's not to go out there and buy a house
and start a family you know what the
number one goal is for college people
who are just now graduating pay off
sickness
is that the american dream
no
the number one mistake i see with your
generation is you take a kids approach
to an adult decision
it's funny talking with my mom and
getting her story of you know i went to
college for four thousand dollars and
thinking to myself
that's cool it's not that cheap now
growing up we were more in the lower
middle class
a single mom
who has two boys
you could tell that
we didn't have an endless supply of
money
for college i ended up opting to go the
business route i saw what the financial
situation was like and realized if i
could create a business and grow that
and then be able to give back how much
more of a difference would that make if
i could fund 20 of me to go to college
u of m in minnesota was my big choice
it's a very large substantial campus and
you get this sense of pride you know
walking into that situation knowing that
this is where i could be cutting my
teeth for going out into the real world
so one day go to the mailbox
i got in that's what i wanted i was
totally set on going there
i'd done everything i needed to up into
that point basically i could coast out
my senior year right i made it to the
next step
that's the funny part they don't send
the tuition with the acceptance letter
that letter also had shock you open it
up
you look at it and 22 000 a year
at that time i'm driving a car i paid
600 bucks for
i was totally ready just to dive deep
into debt because
that's what the journey looks like right
that's what everyone expects it to be
and
i was gonna be one of them
what college are you going to i haven't
like got my financial package from duke
yet but duke is my passion why is duke
your dream school
um i've been to the campus i've toured
and i fell in love with it you fell in
love with like the ex like the classes
the people there the overall like
experience of being there their
connections how much is duke gonna run
you um yearly about 75. oh
it's undergrad so i'm still thinking
about uh
yeah
that's 300 grand yeah no for a degree
yeah
what about you nyu really nyu yeah why
is that your school
because it's like saturated with music
artists with with producers with
opportunities just out at every corner
for music in particular how much is it
uh 75. oh my gosh
75 000
i'm gonna reach for what i can and if
nyu is it then i'm gonna reach
oh my gosh i was so serious please stop
stop
don't leave us
okay so i
toured buffalo back in november and i
don't know i feel like it'll be a lot
like high school as far as like arriving
like there
like i know my parents talked about like
college was like the best years of their
life and died and so i feel like the
experiences that i'm gonna get at
college are gonna be like
unmatched so you're going all the way to
buffalo state just to have an upgraded
high school experience
um
yeah keyword upgraded
well if i wanted to sell a college to
the normal group of semi-unmotivated
semi-uninformed people i would start
with the football team
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i would move on to the parties
[Music]
i would then go on to uh shiny pictures
of people at graduation we are
we are
i wouldn't mention student debt
i wouldn't mention all the hours you
have in between class
because most colleges aren't good at
helping people through that
picking a school is a complicated
process between applications and essays
and costs and visitation and the stuff
out there on the web
it's it's just overwhelming
the average person doesn't know what to
look for because this isn't their world
and then all of a sudden you get thrust
into it and it's information overload
and how do you synthesize it into
something that makes a whole lot of
sense the new 30th edition of best
colleges was just released this morning
and we've got it brian kelly is editor
of u.s news and world report good to see
you again brian kelly
this is getting to be an annual visit we
like it if you were to ask me what's the
worst thing that has happened to higher
education in the last 20 or 30 years
i would say
unabashedly
a fledgling magazine decided to start
ranking colleges
which schools will have the greatest
chance of giving you the american dream
the usual suspects i have to say
princeton harvard yale columbia stanford
are the top five the whole world wants
to go to these places education is a
brand now it's a label that's an
industry one of the things u.s news and
world report measures is the percentage
of people the college rejects that the
more people you reject
the better college you must be i always
look at their alumni they are they're
very loyal alumni people who go to
princeton love princeton they give it
money they come back they stay engaged
with the school that makes a difference
and then they came with this
ever-evolving matrix of points really
important things like your reputation
how other people think about you it
turns into a higher ed arms race it's
like nikes versus
gucci they're both shoes they both work
the same
but one has more value because of the
name
some colleges figured out if they made
their dorms nicer or their gyms fancier
more people would want to come what's up
with their dorms what do they have
beautiful campuses yeah 10 different
residence halls there's a food service
it's pretty awesome
if more people wanted to come they
discovered that u.s news and world
report would rank them higher do you
accept bribes
only very large ones i have been lobbied
by some of the finest people in the
world if u.s news and world report
ranked them higher more people wanted to
come if more people wanted to come they
could charge more because their piece of
paper was worth more so the ratchet kept
turning and it kept turning and it kept
turning the parents are demanding the
college students are demanding it you
have to build it otherwise they won't
come because your college isn't good
enough the idea that you can spend four
years not living at home going to class
three hours a day yeah that's the
definition of privilege wherever you
came from best campus food i mean it is
fabulous wow
so let's be really clear you shouldn't
go to a famous college there's no reason
i hope
you go to a great college but i also
know that some of the cheapest colleges
in america could be great if you make
them great if you use your time there to
have a series of experiences to change
your life and other people's lives
because that's what you get you get four
years of freedom and leverage what are
you going to do with it because if all
you're doing is saying i'm going to give
up four years of my life and all my
money for a piece of paper at the end
well
it doesn't make sense to pay what you're
currently paying for the paper
what really was apparent to me was how
much debt can be that ball and chain on
your ankle when you actually hop into
the real world once you can change that
mental state of debt
actually doesn't have to be an option i
can do this a different way
there's a newfound freedom that comes
with that
going forward with school i knew that i
wanted to pay for it
later on in my senior year when i went
and toured wisconsin lutheran college
i went to the school with the mindset
i'm gonna hate this
i was thinking am i shorting myself by
going to a small school
will i be able to get the job i want to
because i went to a no-name school
everybody knows university of
wisconsin-madison the badgers
how many people know the wisconsin
lutheran college warriors as exciting as
d3 football is i knew we weren't gonna
be known for that
but then when that tuition bill came
paired with some scholarships that i
earned in high school meant i wouldn't
be going in my first year
that was an eye-opener
i'm convinced that most of the mistakes
around college are simply college choice
it's it's simple
30 years ago the difference in cost of a
community college a state school and a
private school was not a lot and the
difference in what you got 30 years ago
in terms of the quality of education was
a lot the weird thing is is that the
quality of education has come up
on the community college so much and on
the state school so much that they're
almost all three parallel now
but the cost went dramatically different
but here's the thing a lot of people get
the basic knowledge of business the
basic knowledge of a communication the
basic knowledge in i.t field at a
community college and get a really good
career out of it information is just
much more accessible now than it was 30
years ago to the average person
so let's talk for a second about whether
you should go to college at all
given that every single course at mit is
available online for free
given that with motivation you could
cover four years of college coursework
in a year
that there are ways to cobble together
what you would learn in college and even
show up with a degree without going in
the front door without paying full price
and the giant shift that's happening is
that the people who are hiring what they
want from you is not that you went to a
school with a better reputation or at
least a better football team what they
want from you is the real skills
creativity honesty directness leadership
resilience and i think we've got to
strip away the easy and fun part stop
rewarding it stop confusing it with a
useful signal
and instead get back to the hard part
which is how we're going to be
productive generous human beings
i'm not i'm not really going to college
to get my degree i'm going to get the
knowledge so my plan was to go keller's
right that's like yeah harvard for
innovation it is yeah and then i was
like i'm set but then
two schools here have animation programs
i was like you know might as well i go
and check out lipscomb's animation
program and it's
the the professors are disney animators
so it's like what i'm getting here in my
home state and home city
and like for free wow instead of getting
into like 400k debt right it's like why
would i not you know wow yeah so you
turned down the
harvard of
animation to come here turn on the
channel okay
you're banking on student loans and work
if not it sounds like you may not be
going to school
that's the reality i've come to face
this year
you still may not be able to go to
school or your dream school
i wouldn't be able to be comfortable at
school but if i don't go to my dream
school
because i've picked my dream schools to
be the schools that i would be happy at
that i would be comfortable at
why
it's like it's the price you pay for
certain things in life because i could
skip out on college and go work a
full-time job won't have any debt but i
won't be happy can't come up with 13 000
a year
so you can't
no
no
i honestly didn't know
how i was gonna pay for year number two
you go through the first year of bliss
but when the tuition bill hits and you
get that letter in your mailbox that
says tuition is going up for next year
no one wants to pay more money for
school
i was fully prepared to take a gap year
or do anything to avoid having debt my
second year and continuing on
college tuition can now cost as much as
50 000 a year but luckily one woman says
she's figured out how to get a college
education for free christina ellis
earned half a million dollars in
scholarships and is the author of
confessions of a scholarship winner
welcome christina nice to see you
a lot of times whenever people hear that
i won a half million dollars in
scholarships they sometimes assume that
like i just got to pocket
anything that i didn't use and they're
like where's the car that you bought and
it's like no that's not how it works
that being said a really cool thing
about pushing for a lot of scholarships
is that you can actually get a refund
check if you live off campus i would
actually get like a ten thousand dollar
check each semester to be able to pay
for my housing and my books and meals
and transportation so winning
scholarships can allow you to have a lot
of freedom and flexibility with how you
live your life while you're in college
what are your thoughts on scholarships
are you all currently applying for any
right now yes and it's like i don't know
where to look right and it's really
overwhelming because you hit so many
dead ends it's like 10 million
scholarships it's just it's overwhelming
it's strange to the library and got
scholarship books in their garbage like
i'm trying
i was aware of scholarships
honestly they were just
a hassle
just too many
non-guarantees in that when i could be
working
because most of them only range from
like 200 to a thousand dollars
and that doesn't even
put a thump in how much tuition is at
most universities
i think it's great to have a
conversation about scholarships your
freshman year because it gives students
time to develop a resume without a lot
of pressure
that being said a lot of students think
that it's too late to apply for
scholarships if they've already started
college and that's just not true there
are scholarships that are available for
students all throughout their college
experience
the gap is really there's a lack of
financial education inside of our
schools and in two this is a lack of
wise counsel along this journey and
we're not taking the time to teach our
young people to step back and to do the
research
if you spend
two hours filling out an application
that allows you to win a thousand dollar
scholarship that's like making 500 an
hour that is significant i mean
what other
part-time job in high school are you
gonna find that makes that amount of
money i decided i want to make looking
at scholarships like my full-time job if
i just hit one of those 500 scholarships
after applying for 10 of them it's still
worthwhile
so much of it is about habits and just
getting in a groove of consistently
putting in the effort it doesn't have to
be so overwhelming if you just break it
down into manageable steps
you may have to come home spend two
hours spend three hours on the internet
grinding you may get a lot of no's but
that one yes that second yes that third
yes is going to be worth all the no's
that you got scholarships are a great
opportunity
[Music]
there are millions of scholarships given
away
every single year for so many different
reasons you can win a scholarship for
being tall
for being short there's a vegetarian
scholarship there's a scholarship for
being a golf caddy for having the best
zombie apocalypse escape plan the
criteria is so broad that it's a numbers
game in many senses
don't write off the 500 scholarship
don't write off the thousand dollar
scholarship because those are often
where students find the most success
there were some i didn't find out until
the last second
and there were some that i got that i
didn't even know i was going to get
if you were still enrolled in a
university you should still do your
research and try to find scholarships if
you are currently taking out student
loans to get through school take a
moment to do some research and see the
vast options available
where you do not have set goals and you
do not go through a series of behaviors
with intentionality you are never going
to be in that area of your life
successful and college is no exception
to that every single day you're being
intentional about the decisions that you
make that's going to get you in college
and through college without borrowing a
dime
it sets in once you apply for graduation
it's like okay i will no longer be in
school
so i no longer have that crutch
of putting it off
because now at this point i am going to
have to come up with a plan
as to
when i'm going to start paying it back
off how much i'm gonna have to start
paying back off and what i can even
afford to pay back off
and there's a bunch of stuff that come
with adulthood that you just don't
account for
it does kind of make me worry about
what am i going to do then you know like
i don't want to still be paying back
student loans when i'm supposed to be
nearing retirement
but being realistic and like looking at
it's like well maybe i won't be because
13 000 can
turn into 25 000
easily depending on how i manage that
because it's a lot of my peers who leave
a four-year university and still don't
have a job for six months
and that's where you have to start
paying back your student loans so it's
like what do you do
[Music]
moving to van wert
we tried
buying a home like it wasn't a very nice
home but
it was in well means
and we applied for loan and got denied
definitely like put us in perspective
like we would never get a house
we wouldn't be able to have kids like
we're not going to be able to live
we had a point in time
where we actually
did not go shopping for a full month
and we didn't have food
outside of basically some boxed pasta
and like watered down spaghetti sauce
because we didn't we did not have enough
money to literally go afford
to buy groceries and that's with every
credit card maxed out everything like
just literally backs to the wall pinned
up against it
like we've officially hit rock bottom
i just looked back at that money amount
and realized like what what did it
actually get me
i know it got me a college degree and i
know it got me
experiences
but the college degree and experience is
worth 125 000
we don't think anymore we just do
so much of our mental health challenges
in this country are because we let our
feelings and our emotions drive our day
college choice is no different
we've gotten so unintentional about it
and then we figure out we're going to
pay for it later
now we blinked there's a couple of
trillion dollars floating around out
there on the backs of 19 20 25 year olds
40 year olds it's just becoming like a
car payment like a mortgage that's just
a payment we have that's a way of life
and we've got to recenter that
so who's the first person on the
schedule
it's a consult
okay
when i was 10 i got hit in the mouth of
the golf ball so it like broke my two
front teeth and unfortunately i was the
one that hit the golf ball so it came
back and hit me right in the mouth
i was kind of in and out of the dentist
office as a kid
so that's what got me interested in
orthodontics
i got out of undergrad debt-free
but then it uh
quickly went the other direction
finished dental school i had probably
somewhere around 400 000 in in student
loans
ortho and oral surgery are the two most
competitive residencies
and a majority of programs i mean they
only have three or four seats each year
and they probably have 1500 applications
so i mean you have to be up in the top
of your class to even get an interview
all right you just got to stay biting
down to hold that in place for me okay
once i was in residency the tuition was
95 000 a year
i mean at that point i mean what i
didn't have any other options it was
either
you know you're not gonna be an
orthodontist or this is what you're
gonna do
there is a quote-unquote bottomless pit
of money if you will
i consider private loan folks the same
as payday lenders there's always a place
to go find money right it's going to
cost you your soul but there's money out
there if you want to go do the things
you got to do to go get it
we're seeing private educational loans
becoming larger and larger and larger
where there's no real governmental
control like there is under the federal
programs for those you're at the mercy
of your lender and for that i can't tell
you what's going to happen
but you're at the mercy of a private
credit-based lender and you owe tens of
thousands of dollars
[Music]
good luck
think about it like a car payment you've
agreed this much money over this many
months at this much amount to pay it
back when you don't
we want it give me your pound of flesh
now
and that pound of flesh can come in all
different ways but they have to sue you
to get that then you have now a judgment
against you that they can then do other
things for instance garnish a paycheck
if you have one
garnish a bank account if you have one
you possess a vehicle if you own it
to be made whole because they light you
money what we also have to think about
though with that is roughly 90 of those
are co-signers so the co-signer could be
mom or dad
grandma and grandpa is a huge one
and there's nothing worse sitting around
thanksgiving table telling grandpa you
can't pay that
and grandpa already knows because he was
served with a lawsuit too
we had borrowers with private student
loans where they would be paying their
loan on time faithfully and their like
parent or grandparent who co-signed
their loans died and instantly despite
the fact they were paying they're like
now you're in default give us all give
us all our money
i had someone she was in a horrific car
accident paralyzed her and
um her mother was killed in the car
accident which triggered the default on
the private student loans
she was hoping to get back to work she
was
you know working for her degree in
nursing and she had a closed head injury
and i thought okay this this is the case
this is it we can do this
um and the court and that at the end of
the day because she was gonna qualify
most likely for on social security
disability that meant that she had the
ability to pay it back
but i want to try to figure out how to
make stuffing i think if i add some
broth to it
it won't be so good it won't be dry yeah
but we'll try it and see
one way to find out
when it came to student loans like you
could get whatever you wanted
there's problems on both sides of that
the people that are giving the money and
the people that are taking the money
i mean 95 000 times 15 residents
you're talking
1.3 million dollars in tuition from 15
people
and the international residents that
were there paid 140 000 in tuition every
year
140.
you're you're a number you're you're a
paycheck
and who you're surrounded by in those
years are people who probably know
nothing about personal finance have the
same loans that you have
and you literally just
you do everything you can just to not
even think about it
it's not like i'm getting a loan and
they're giving me the money and then i
have to actually give it to the school
i never saw it it was scary but at that
point you're just like whatever man
with all the interest and everything
that i already had on my loans i
probably had 500 or 600 000
i'm like sure just throw it on there
[Music]
you want to go ahead and take him back
and do that
okay
it's a ton of money and it is it's scary
and i think early on too it was just we
had to have like a lot of like hard
conversations about it
how are we gonna pay it off
do we just go on a minimum repayment
plan and you just pay it off for forever
like how do you even begin to get out of
it
the people who are writing the loans
and they don't care
i just got an offer on my student loans
like oh you qualified to lower your your
interest rate well why'd you wait till i
have 300 000 in interest to lower my
interest rate
why don't you lower it before
because you just wanted all the interest
these student loans you know they never
go away
unlike so much other debt that can be
forgiven you know in the wake of a
bankruptcy for instance it's like
stepping in gum man it's with you
forever and ever and ever
so it is accruing about 6 000 of
interest every month
mr frostman
you are now recognized for five minutes
to present your oral testimony
over the course of the last decade i
traveled all across this country
talking to thousands of people
in big cities small towns and nearly
every slice of america in between
and from these conversations i have
found that one aspect of life cuts
across
the fallout from extraordinary student
debt
there are now more than 8 million
student loan borrowers in default
we had a million student loan borrowers
default last year a year before that the
year before that year before that so if
you do the math that means every 28
seconds another student loan borrower
defaults on its loan
on top of that we have three million
more borrowers who are behind that's
over 10 million people or one out of
four student loan borrowers who are
having their financial lives ruined as
they can't
make their payments
people with student debt have just felt
invisible you take on debt that's what
you're supposed to do this is good debt
stop complaining but the ramifications
for your financial life are the same if
not worse like student loan borrowers
have less rights less protections and we
use the full weight of the government to
make sure you pay that back
i look at all the things that are going
on right here and i'm just article after
article what certainly seems like a very
large amount of corruption
in 2009 sallie mae's ceo said quote if a
borrower can create condensation on a
mirror they need to get a loan this year
in order to put their subprime lending
in place navien forwarded wrong
information to credit reporting agencies
saying that permanently disabled
veterans had defaulted on their loans
when they hadn't then you have itt
credit union using financial aid staff
to rush students
through an automated application process
when they knew that they had projected
default rates as high as 64
so they were setting people up to fail
these are a series of public policy
choices at the federal government at the
state government that have gotten us
here
i think this is the intersection between
so much debt and illegal practices right
because there's this enormous mismatch
between what borrowers are promised and
what's happening on the ground
and in between our student loan
companies this is not just some one-off
company or like one bad apple
you see players across the student loan
spectrum who just view this as their
chance to get wretch
my name is lynn sabolsky i am a former
employee of nadine's call center
i thought it was going to be a really
easy straightforward job that i would
understand the rules that i would
perform well
the longer i was there i started to
notice
red flags
people were being asked to lie
people were not being given the right
information
in general there was just this
oppressive
environment
that wasn't really allowing the
representatives to do the job that they
were being paid to do
there is a memo that navient council
told and had the mantra to the people
that you would call those customer
service people for bear for bear for
bear get these people that way
forbearance an agreement to postpone
your loan payments while interest
continues to accrue
when naviance puts an account in
forbearance they get to collect the
interest those loan balances increase
they are now collecting interest on top
of interest that is the most beneficial
scenario for them
we sued one of the biggest student loan
companies in the country navient
and a single claim
as part of that lawsuit documented how
the practices of this company added 4
billion with a b
dollars of unnecessary interest onto the
most vulnerable borrowers
mr fuhrman our friends across the aisle
have mentioned that student loan
services are supposedly not incentivized
to steer borrowers toward forbearance
and that they are not financially
incentivized to give borrowers poor or
outright incorrect advice yet an audit
released by the doe in february this
year found that more than 60 percent of
the department's oversight report
contained examples of servicers acting
improperly if our friends across the
aisle are correct and loan services are
not incentivized to make mistakes and
give poor advice then why is this
consistently happening because they're
wrong because they are incentivized to
give bad advice they're incentivized to
get their call reps off the phone as
quick as possible which we see across
the industry leading to the outcomes we
have today
this part of our training was keeping
your calls to seven minutes if i don't
keep my call to seven minutes i have a
lower status at the end of the day i'm
considered not having performed as well
if you're a representative and your
choice is give this person the help they
need or get in trouble in some way shape
or form
then really you're you're pitting one
person against the other
i was talking to my coworkers over lunch
and over break and a few of my
co-workers said that there was just no
way to answer all of those questions in
a way that was satisfactory and maintain
the numbers that we were maintaining and
so they would be on their call and then
they would just press a button and go
oops
we're sorry dial again
funny enough navient's still in business
making a kajillion dollars a year and
still has contracts with the federal
government
angry yet
on the shoreline of maui's wailea beach
at the luxurious fairmont hotel
sallie mae executives and more than a
hundred of its employees are on a
five-day paid trip
celebrating a record year 5 billion in
student loans to 374 000 borrowers
planning session and recognition of
accomplishments for our sales force has
been something that has been done i'm
going to say since the company was
founded in 1972 and it's recognition of
the hard work but it's an important
piece of planning
i think we're done
that is like a general sentiment that we
hear
frequently which is we love
getting
the money to be involved in the student
loan system but when it actually comes
to doing the work to help borrowers to
avoid the defaults you know how dare you
accuse us of of being part of the
problem
and so we sued this company in court and
one of their top legal arguments were
judge you should dismiss this case
because we have no actual responsibility
to help followers
i'm being cheated out of
my paycheck
i could retire two years after
i'm done paying my student loans it's
like paying for retirement
and literally never seeing a dime of it
ever again you should know the names of
the companies that have targeted your
constituents
citibank discover bank
navient fia quinn street sallie mae sofi
transworld wells fargo
and the list goes on
in a way there's no
morality in the student loan system
because
there is no one that's going to stop you
from borrowing at the end of the day
it's just you know
you type a couple buttons in and on the
other side there's a student loan with
some numbers that is the most
personal it gets
so this right here is
my uh
college diploma um
don't even take it out of the envelope
in fact i had to have my mother
mailed to me because i didn't know where
it was
so let's see
stamped signed and sealed
that's not going to ever be framed i'm
not going to
ever leave this envelope again and
ensure i can have the degree
allows me to do something that i love to
do in
but this piece of paper is something
that has brought a lot of pain in my
life
i don't really want to look at it
you can talk to someone who's graduated
10 years ago
and they still
owe
student loans
so it's like if i can meet a complete
stranger
and this is what we have in common
that's an issue
the borrower slave to the lender and
like that's so true
when you have
this kind of debt or really any debt
like you
you feel that
it changes
who you are and how you can
behave
it changes your life
you've arrived at your destination the
choices that they made now own them
and they were led down this primrose
path
by a set of values
put on them by a series of guidance
counselors and parents who weren't
thinking educators who were out of
control and a congress who continues
this ridiculous student loan debacle and
here they sit trapped
and they do not know what to do
i try to do this without crying
i feel like
when he told me
how much shitload that he had
it wasn't gonna make me change the way i
felt about him like you're dead
is it
bringing you down as a person you know
millions of americans are struggling
with the same problem like it's not just
your fault
i like i don't care how much diet he'll
ever have like i would still always love
him
but i don't think he realized that
i feel like i've failed
as the provider as the husband
because i'm the reason that we're in so
much debt
we only had a total of about 142 000
120 some of that is my college
it's literally like saying you're the
reason your team is losing if they if
you weren't on this team we'd be winning
but because of one thing
it takes everybody down with it
the first hardest thing it was for me
was right after we got married we could
not go on a honeymoon and i know that
sounds like cliche but like you don't
realize
you'll never have that like
moment that like time again like
newlyweds get to go to like this awesome
place like it's something you look
forward to when you get married and like
we lost out on like that time
that was hard
i know she still loves me no matter what
and i'm so grateful for that but it
stopped us from
being able to get a house when we moved
down to vane where
and it stopped us for a long time from
not having kids
like i'm not being the man that i'm
supposed to be
looking at you know what it's gonna look
like to actually attempt to to pay it
off
paying somewhere around ten thousand
dollars a month you know
sounds like it's gonna
you know actually do something but it's
not gonna do as much as you'd like to
think that it will
at some point it's gonna have to be
you know you're paying 20 30 40 000 a
month
to be able to pay 30 or 40 000 a month i
mean you gotta
you gotta be making
a lot of money
you know i think
realizing you know what it is
um
it just uh
you know just knowing that
[Music]
you know it's probably not going to be
possible
you know without
the help of god i mean
how am i gonna make that much money
but all you can do is try so
there are a lot of people who quite
rightfully say i did everything i was
told to do now i'm in a boatload of debt
i'm not happy about it
how are we going to keep this cycle from
repeating itself
well to the first group of people i'm
sorry
that
you shouldn't have trusted the system
the system let you down
how do we keep from repeating it is
stop telling people this is what they're
supposed to do stop telling people that
this is the path
it might be easier it's definitely more
fun in the short run
but here it is with subtitles this is
not what you're supposed to do what
you're supposed to do is figure out how
to make a contribution
not figure out how to make a marketing
industrial governance system happy in
the short run
what was the first step you took in
terms of you
getting out the lifestyle that you were
yeah
changed my mind
what are you putting inside of this
that comes out of this
that comes out of this
a degree that y'all are trying to get is
a small degree when it comes to your
life
this right here is everything
and when i changed what i was putting up
here
that's when my whole life changed
each and every single one of you all
need to
have a clear vision
of what you want to do the vision is not
i want to go to this school
i want to have this experience no what
is the vision for your life
i want to have options
i want freedom
the question is
are you willing to put in the work up
front
if you can grasp that
you will be successful
going into my senior year i knew it
would be close
i can do the math so can you
working at a normal hourly job would not
pay the necessary 14 000
i needed for school
i knew what i had to do
i went for something with more
opportunity and that was a sales
commission job and really went and made
the most of it
usually work four days a week ten hour
shifts and then on my off days i would
sell lawn mowers and flip them driving
across the state
hey how's it going good how about you
good
it's right over here
little did i know that there was so much
opportunity in it
well
i know you had it listed for six but
just take five on it cash
we gotta teach young people how to
really take ownership of their life
if they're paying something out of their
pocket they will take their education
experience a little bit more serious
because now they can say my parents
didn't pay for it we paid for it
this is just simplistic to me it's
something i understand and
i don't think lawn mowers is for
everybody
someone who's interested in shoes would
be better suited to do something like
that
as long as you have knowledge in an area
you can probably figure out a way to
make money with it
during this expensive period if you have
the resources
and the time
how will you choose to spend it
so that when the system tries to squeeze
you you can say no thank you
got these pictures uploaded gotta
do some cropping get them posted
then wait
there was one guy i
bought a bigger zero turn paid 1700
bucks brought it home washed it listed
it
sold it for 2 600. same day
my mom would just be dumbfounded
are you sure you're allowed to do that
mom it's selling lawnmowers i don't know
what else you want
[Music]
you definitely have a lot of noise
around you saying take out loans you're
not able to do this
once you find that window of opportunity
though and realize that if you repeat
this process over and over like i did
with lawn mowers
there's just so much empowerment and
that feeling of running after this goal
and chasing it down and putting
everything you have into it
that's hard to explain
all right she's all ready to go
yep
when you start opening your eyes and
looking to these unique opportunities
you can add value in unique ways
all good
in total that summer i probably made
around 13 000
[Music]
at that point i could say i'm getting
out of these four years debt-free
i don't know for a while to go here but
we are
oh sweet
that's cool
so i remember once when i was in
undergrad and i asked my history
professor
why did they send all these 18 and 19
year old
u.s soldiers
to the normandy innovation
and he said something that shook me he
said because any
combat veteran who saw that plan would
have said no way
d-day worked
because of some extraordinary planning
some extraordinary sacrifice
and what he said was good old-fashioned
unabated
american teenage
arrogance because they got up in front
and told those boys
nine out of ten of you will not come
home
90 out of 100 of you are not coming back
and those guys in line went
sucks to be that guy right and they did
that all the way down
because when you're a teenager you're
invincible that's gonna happen to
somebody else
and so
i have to know
no matter how honest i'm being and how
upfront i'm being hey this is expensive
and you're gonna have to pay this back
i have to know that my end consumer the
18 year old's going okay we'll get there
and has no understanding
of what seven hundred dollars a month
actually feels like out of a 2 400 a
month paycheck
i'm just i feel like i'm just so worried
about like
having to sacrifice my happiness for
like a cheaper route like having to
sacrifice what really makes me happy and
brings you joy on a day-to-day basis
just to save money like happiness is
worth anything like you know what i mean
like that's the part i'm confused on
like if you're not happy in life at that
given moment
no matter what it takes what does it
really matter the happiness later on
i'm not saying you can't be happy
i want you to be happy
but i feel as if your happiness comes
from something that is
outside of education
and i feel as if you're looking for
something to confirm something on the
internal side of you
not something to help you grow as a man
because if you're looking for the
education
then you can get the education anywhere
but from what you said
you just want to go there so you can
have a good time
i would really step back and ask myself
what's more important
happiness for four years
that cost me 30.
or
a little bit of happiness but hard work
that really makes me happy for the rest
of my life
and if it was me i'm saying man i'm
putting into work
i look back at my four years and this is
the time of my life
i got to travel a bunch for really cheap
been to alaska california texas florida
but the reality is
it's not the buildings
it's not the sports
it's not the land around the school that
make the experience
that's all up to you
it's not the school that's gonna change
that
so which one of these are you sitting
i'm way
like over there
you'll have to get your binoculars out
and squint a little actually
i did
you know what the difference is between
a normal person and someone who is not
normal is the not normal person was
willing to do the things that normal
people
are not willing to do
i do not want to live the majority of my
life not being able to do what i want to
do because i got to pay for things in my
past that's the normal i refuse to be a
part of
students need to begin by saying i
refuse to be brainwashed into believing
that if i get into a good college it
means i'm better than if i don't
so go find a door you can afford and go
through that door
and figure out how to marshal the
resources you need whether it's
scholarships or
only going part-time or taking a gap
year and working like crazy to put 25
000 in the bank so at least your first
year you're not starting with free and
easy money you're going to be paying off
for decades
it never was the degree that caused
people to succeed it was the knowledge
base the tools in their belt to be able
to get their work done
that's what caused people to succeed it
still is what causes people to succeed
whether you can demonstrate that you
have the skills to do the job is going
to be a much higher indicator than where
you went to school or for that matter
even if you have the degree
[Music]
i think there's a real opportunity
for guidance counselors and parents to
talk to their kids
about how they want to work
as opposed to what they want to do
i think a smarter thing to tell
a person who's trying to figure out what
to be when they grow up
is to say put it all on the table
and if you do that
you're liable to be a very happy
satisfied plumber making six figures a
year or perhaps running your own
mechanical contracting company
it's not the job that makes you happy
it's you
[Music]
so what this is really about is freedom
it's about earning the freedom to decide
what you're going to do next david james
wilson bachelor of arts business
administration summa [ __ ] laude
here's the secret to you while being
successful
you're not looking at the picture today
you're looking at the end picture what
kind of future do you want
and the choices you're making now will
impact it
i can choose what opportunities i want
i can choose where i want to live
i can decide my job
i can focus my time on things that
matter to me
which will lead to greater satisfaction
down the road
the best feeling is knowing that this
journey that i'm starting with the rest
of life
i don't have to carry any baggage with
me
can you imagine getting off that stage
going home walking into your job for the
very first time it's your career and
when you get that first paycheck that
paycheck is yours
can you imagine
having freedom at 22 making 35 40 45 000
a year
walking the stage debt-free is not just
about walking the stage debt-free but
you're walking into life
debt-free
[Music]
welcome
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]